some of this just comes down to
temperament and we start the book with a
quote from
adam newman's high school driving
instructor adam's
either going to be a millionaire or he's
going to jail those are the two options
there's no like nice steady adam newman
work his way up the ranks
at some job he was he was a go big kind
of person
and the question was going to be whether
he he ended up
being successful with that risk or or
falling on his face or both
or both
what have you spent the last couple of
years researching
well i've spent about the last year and
a half researching
wework the company and and the last few
years
researching sort of the world of i guess
high growth unicorn startups um is
is one way of of putting it some of
which
um have flamed out in one way or another
and some of which are
are still with us so is wework
classed as one of those unicorns and
what what is a unicorn for people that
don't
live in silicon valley what's a unicorn
sure sure well there's there's
there's unicorns there's zebras there's
all kinds of different species now but
it but a unicorn very um
simply is a company that according to
private valuations set by private
investors is worth more than a billion
dollars
um and you know there there are now
um certainly more than 100 of these
[Music]
kinds of companies and wework uh despite
all those troubles
remains one of those
those companies that are unicorns are
they
still private or of some of those
transition to now be
traded yeah the the the typical way it's
sort of looked at is is these are um
you know they are magical creatures they
exist outside of the way the
the markets traditionally treat these
companies so so
unicorns are generally companies that
are that are private before
um before they hit the stock market
which and then you are no longer a
unicorn once you do
i you are you're not i don't know like
what you transform into exactly
and like the silicon valley nomenclature
but
but you you you yeah it's it's sort of
like caterpillar butterfly thing but i
don't know what the next like
transformation is
got you if anyone understands the
pokemon game that is
silicon valley sufficiently well what
does the unicorn evolve it's charizard
isn't it
charizard and then you get the shiny one
and then that's everyone at school wants
you
cards well you're you're joking i i
think but
but truthfully there there is there is
another
group called a decacorn and a decacorn
is uh is an even rarer breed of company
um that has a private valuation above 10
billion dollars
and wework was was um uh was one of
those
i guess that is actually a qualification
that the company has has now lost
um what who else is in that uh category
of the old deckacon do you know
you know i'd have to think i mean airbnb
is one that is
um is uh sort of
going public has said they're they're
going public soon
um i think palantir which also went
public recently
uh is is another one that that would
have classified it's
it's a pretty small group and it and it
has traditionally been kind of the
biggest companies the ubers
the lifts um and and the we works that
that reach that kind of
uh threshold have you had a look at much
to do with
the electric scooter lime
and bird and all of this there was a
period was it towards the start of last
year
where they were doubling their valuation
every six weeks like
all of them yeah well and
here here in the us they seem to find a
new city um to occupy
uh every every um every few weeks and
and um yeah i mean those are the kinds
of companies that we're talking about
and i think
one of them i'm i'm forgetting exactly
but i think bird may have at one point
had a had a billion dollar valuation
which is
i mean you know if you want to kind of
summarize the last decade
uh a billion dollar scooter company that
didn't exist a few years ago
is is which by the way i was i was
recently in
nashville tennessee um and
tried to get a bird scooter i think
technically i was trying to get a lime
scooter going
their birds their limes there's like
five or six different companies in all
these cities and i
i could not could not get the app going
could not get
the scooter to stop chirping at me and
eventually
um eventually just gave up on it so uh
it's unclear exactly what what the
billion dollar evaluation is
is um is worth there's some
executive from bird and lime screaming
into their airpods at the moment going
it was your fault
this wasn't us this was we tested it to
the until the cows come home
yeah well you know unfortunately uh the
scooter is no good without the human
um human to get on it so uh
i i guess maybe take the app back back
it's interesting with that just to sort
of linger on that scooter thing for a
second as well
it really does show how decoupled
valuation has come
from marketability there are entire
cities that have outlawed these scooters
i think is it san francisco
had decided that they were going to
permit one or two scooter companies
at a time to trial because they didn't
want overload it's that right
here's the six week window where
everyone can have a go on a lime here's
a six-week window window where everyone
can have a go on a bird
yeah that's right and i i live in new
york city where um
they um they aren't allowed and and it's
been kind of a
political back and forth of do we want
these these scooters you know cluttering
up our
our sidewalks and and the battle we've
had there recently or sort of the back
and forth was
was there's now multiple kinds of
scooters we have we have these scooters
called revels which are
you know you actually sit back it's
almost sort of like a vespa an electric
vespa and um several people have died
and and you know the the companies
shut down for a while but then they kind
of brush it
brush it off and and sort of continue
continue expanding so it is
the the scooter wars are sort of an
interesting and and
weird dynamic that's now in in pretty
much every city at this point
i can see you or an equivalently
talented writer
coming up with a really interesting book
about that in maybe five years once we
have a little bit more story arc about
all of this
because it's such a like pokemon power
rangers
battle of the sort of weird novelty
uh personal locomotion world
right and which one's going to win you
know and and what's what's the
difference between them and
and it is i mean you know it's actually
is something i've i've thought about and
i think one of the interesting things
about
a lot of these kinds of companies some
of the ones we're talking about but the
scooter ones specifically is
these are silicon valley startups that
are taking that kind of ethos
and bringing it into like the real
physical world like this is not a piece
of software that just exists somewhere
this is suddenly there are
scooters all over my city and and
there's good parts of that and there's
bad parts of that
and you can argue both sides i despite
the story i just told you
have enjoyed riding these scooters um in
in other
situations and i think there there may
be a very good argument for them but
but they do put these companies in kind
of an interesting place that they
weren't in 10 years ago which is that
silicon valley startups typically um
preferred to kind of choose to believe
that the real world was sort of over
there
and and that they didn't necessarily
have to think about
how their whatever they were working on
sort of
what effect it had on the broader world
beyond whatever they want to do and
now these companies are having to deal
with city councils
and politicians and local businesses
real [ __ ]
things yeah real [ __ ] and and and i i
remember i i
one of the first of these companies i
wrote about was uber back in 2017
and um this was when travis kalanick the
founder of uber
um was around the time that he was
ousted from the company
the company was going through all this
all this terminal i remember talking to
an
advisor who the company had hired who
sort of uh his job was to kind of help
startups deal with politics and he was
so frustrated that all these companies
just wanted to believe that they could
go into any of these cities do whatever
they want because in their view they
were making it better
and not realize that they're now part of
an ecosystem and and that while there
are great things
about uber about scooters about wework
um you know when you get into the
physical world you're suddenly
dealing with more than just bits and and
data so
that's a lovely open loop into the story
of wework isn't it
yeah so where do we begin what's the
people who are listening don't have a
clue what wework is
they've probably gone past them in the
street the sign but
maybe haven't realized give us the
whatever it's called the cliff notes on
work as a company
well well in a nice loop the story
really begins
i mean given the era that we're in it
begins in the last recession and it
begins in
in kind of 2008 when um adam newman
who was one of the co-founders of wework
along with miguel mckelvey an architect
long story short got together and
decided to
they wanted to bake make what was
basically an office leasing company and
and they were both sort of had worked in
in small businesses
miguel had worked at a small
architecture firm he had also worked at
a tech startup before
um and adam uh had a few of his own
businesses um
and and they've been they've been
written about before uh somewhat
humorously one of them was a
baby clothes business where the main
feature of the product was that they had
knee pads
um the idea was that babies when they
crawl
their knees must hurt um even if they
can't
speak and and tell adults that that
their knees hurt
um it didn't quite work but it did
become a real baby clothes business um
and and he tried a few other things and
and so you know it in sort of the depths
of the recession in 2008 when
when you know companies were crumbling
um they started this business to to
lease
um lease out just basically take a space
cut it up into smaller pieces and lease
it out to people
and and it worked great and and there
are all kinds of reasons that
it worked great they built a nice space
uh people at that time were looking for
community
you were getting laid off from your job
and maybe you were starting to freelance
and
you wanted a place to go which i think
we can all kind of empathize with
with now even though we're sort of
dealing with a different set of
circumstances
um so that's that's sort of where the
business began
and and then from there it it grew
um you know pretty steadily
and and then eventually pretty
exponentially
um to become a global office-based
business
um operating more or less under the same
principles
um that then morphed into other things
um it morphed into becoming a tech
company or aspiring to become
a tech company it morphed into becoming
what what adam liked to call a community
company that wework was not in the
business of
real estate but they were in the
business of bringing people together and
and under that umbrella
the wework eventually had apartments um
they had a gym um they had an elementary
school
and all manner of other kind of business
lines that that were
eventually assembled under a mission
statement that the company revealed that
the beginning of last year which
is to elevate the world's consciousness
um which we can dive into what exactly
that means that's actually a question
that i
asked adam newman himself um but that's
that's sort of the
the long story of the rise of wework um
and and then
you know uh the the short
or the short version i guess and the
short version of the fall is that the
company tried to go public
um the stock market looked at a company
that had all of those things that i just
talked about that
made some money but also lost two
billion dollars
um in in 2018 alone
um and decided that this was not a good
business frankly and and that they
didn't have faith in the business and
and sort of in pretty much the most
spectacular kind of
ipo failure anyone can remember the
company
pulled its ipo um adam newman was pushed
out um
and uh he is sort of spending spending
his days at the moment
um well uh surfing
and waiting for a payout and and seeing
seeing kind of what what happens next
but
that's the the short
that's the cliff notes versions of the
the book i just wrote
dudes i mean i've watched before
reading uh your book i'd watched a bunch
of different videos that have been done
on it the guy's name is going to escape
me australian dude youtuber
who does some really great
again everyone's just going to be
screaming down their airpods at me it'll
come to me anyway
um i noticed over the last two years or
so
quite a lot of high-profile youtubers
who are interested in this sort of stuff
documenting
this slow-motion third trimester car
crash
that is the wework kind of downfall
just before we go back i want to get
into adam newman because i think he's
kind of the crux to all of this
what what actually happened with the ipo
like did
do you need like a particular amount of
interest before you go public
why why was it a failure yeah well you
know
the public often thinks of ipos of like
oh am i am i going to invest in this and
is this going to be the next apple and
it's
is this going to pay for my kids college
education like an ipo is very
specifically
a company needs money and they need to
raise it and in wework's case they were
trying to raise three billion dollars
um and you know as part of these
ipo road shows which is what all these
companies are doing now although they
don't they don't actually go on the road
anymore
um is they go around to investors um
they give them
a document it's called an s-1 it's a
document that's
filed with the sec in the united states
um and and then they give them a
presentation they say here's how our
business works
um you know they're supposed to sort of
be honest and forthcoming about
some of the potential problems and then
investors have to decide uh whether or
not they want to invest and this is
going to
this is going to institutions some a
place like fidelity that might be able
to invest a billion dollars on its own
if it wanted to
into an ipo of this size and
and essentially what happened is is for
a variety of reasons
and and we can talk about them um
investors just just
decided that that the company wasn't
worth what it what it said it was and
and there wasn't enough interest and so
um eventually once once it was clear
wework wasn't
gonna be able to raise the three billion
dollars or at least that there was a
danger
um that it wouldn't get there uh for a
handful of reasons they decided to
to pull it um how would you describe
adam newman as a person and a ceo
two different questions but but they are
related um
charismatic um outgoing
very tall uh he's six five which
which is um often noted but i think is
not an insignificant thing
for for someone like him who's whose
charm and charisma and personality
and vision um were what people were
buying as much as they were buying
sort of the the numbers that that were
behind
um behind the business um
as a ceo um you know the thing people
always talk about
was that he is that that he was someone
who could
get into a room and and that might be a
room with potential investors
uh it might be a room with a landlord he
was trying to make a deal with
um and it might be a room with his
employees and and that he was able
to convince them that what he was
selling
would become true that that this vision
of
of wework as much more than an office
leasing
company um was was possible and
and that and that they were actually
building that and i think that was
like whatever people want to say about
them he was an incredibly
inspirational leader um and that went
for
young people who were straight out of
college uh as much as it did for sort of
mid-career people who came in
and and and saw something
to kind of latch on to i mean billy
mcfarland
from five festival was a very
charismatic and
outgoing ceo
indeed and uh for this book i
called billy in prison no way
yeah okay and we we spoke uh briefly
um just as coronavirus was was sort of
hitting in the spring um so it was
obviously a tense
tense moment for him and the reason i
called him
is that uh he launched his
companies from wework offices he was a
wework tenant
um and in fact this sort of mild amount
of news that that we break in the book
is is that um his company before the
fire fest
before fire um was called magnesis
and magnesis was a sort of credit card
uh club access kind of company basically
a lifestyle company and
at one point magnesis had a we work
office in new york
and billy had met adam a number of times
he sort of
talked to me about how at least the way
that he thinks of
thought of his companies as as um at
least at their
higher aspiration as connecting people
um
he he saw he saw that vision in in adam
and sort of what he was selling and
and at one point wework and magnesis
were in talks we were in talks to buy
magnesis
it would sort of be the kind of
lifestyle component to go along with the
wework work component
um unfortunately uh billy and his
company trashed a townhouse
where they had a party in new york the
deal fell apart
and the rest is history in multiple ways
both adam and billy
went their separate directions and i
guess in a certain way they
they came back together in in the way
that their stories ended a little bit
but
i wonder what i would love to be a fly
in the wall
in a meeting between adam newman and
billy mcfarland man
did you ever see did you see that
podcast between
grant cardone and the real wolf of wall
street
oh i didn't okay well it's it's like a
big dick measuring competition they get
them out on the table and they start
wiggling them around
and then grant wiggles his and then wolf
wall street wiggles here and it's just
that and i imagine
billy mcfarlane versus adam newman would
be something similar
yeah and i think you know i mean i
remember watching the fire
festival documentaries which i devoured
and and you know you
watch at least for me i would watch
billy and i would be like
this is the guy that that was so
charming and charismatic
but then you know and and in some ways i
had that feeling
when when i met adam but um of
questioning this a little bit but then i
think it's hard to know
when you sort of get into these rooms
and and people people also are
incentivized to believe
they they want you know people wanted
the fire festival to happen people
wanted wework
to change the world to make it a better
place so
so you know it's it's easy to think you
sort of look at this sort of skeptically
but then i think when you get in the
room
you know there's a reason they they
appeal to people
i think i wonder if you agree that the
same compulsion we all have
of why we watched the fire festival
documentary and fell in love with
that sort of thing where you're kind of
watching through your hands a little bit
like how you watch a horror movie
at a much more transparent and
slower and significantly in terms of
capital bigger
scale i think that's why wework has
warranted
a book written by yourself and all of
these videos i've seen online with you
know like hundreds of millions of plays
and stuff like that
would you agree is that the is that the
primary
um pull like the reason that people are
compelled
to look at wework yeah i think there's
there's a there's probably a variety of
things uh
ja rule plays a role in in the wework
story as well so he is
that guy is everywhere he's everywhere
he's everywhere and i
i um you know good for him but uh
but i think there's i mean more
seriously yeah
like i mean i'd be curious to know why
why
sort of what you think um makes the fire
festival and wework especially
interesting but for me it's you know one
of it is is
there's a certain comeuppance that that
comes for people
and and you know with with wework
you know i would imagine um as you sort
of said at the top like
a lot of your listeners they probably
knew what wework was they
they they might have been to one or or
at least had heard of it but they didn't
really pay much attention to it
and then same thing with the fire fest
like most people didn't know what it was
until kind of after it had blown up and
then and then
in hindsight you sort of see like oh
like
jaw rules there and you tried to do this
thing
in in however many weeks and of course
this wasn't one
gonna work and and so i think it's it's
it is fun and satisfying too and
same thing with we work you know you've
got this tall haired guy who
smokes a lot of weed and surfs a lot
who started in elementary school in an
office leasing business
of course this this wasn't going to work
and people were saying that along the
way and there were certainly people who
as they said that
once it happened they they um felt sort
of
um rewarded for their their skepticism
and then i think for the rest of us it's
just kind of
the enjoyment of watching a train wreck
yeah it feels like
um vindication
that someone has potentially got their
comeuppance i think that's that's part
of it
i wonder whether companies like five
festival
and wework are latent pressure release
valves
for all of our pent up distrust and
dislike of
other unicorny companies that we think
like
holy [ __ ] calm calm
meditation at thumbtack thumbnail are we
being serious
like do you know what i mean like all of
these everybody knows the
the big lie of silicon valley at the
moment is that
companies are being sold on this
limitless upside scalability
but not all of them are going to make it
and yet all of them are being invested
in as if they are
and i think that particular instances
like this are kind of the the um
sacrificial lamb to the slaughter
that allows all of us to bestow our like
distrust towards silicon valley
generally it just happens to have fallen
on adam newman
and uh thingy mcfarlane's shoulders yeah
i think i think that's right and i
i talked to a guy who ran a company that
was sort of competitive with wework in
the early days and
and for a variety of reasons you know
this guy's done fine for himself his
his business still exists he's done
great he's very wealthy
um he didn't go on the kind of
blitz scaled i'm going to take over the
world path um
that adam did and and he talked to me
about how and this was
we spoke um last spring when i was sort
of reporting on the company before
everything
uh fell apart in the spring of 2019 and
he talked to me about how
you know the reason he cared about the
story was
it felt like if adam gets away with this
then like what are the rules like and
and what are the rules
frankly and this is like from a die-hard
capitalist like
worked in finance went to business
school he's like he's like he was
basically saying
what is capitalism good for um if if you
can just kind of play
fast and loose uh with the rules if the
whole goal is to grow big
not worry about consequences um then
then maybe this whole system we've we've
set up like isn't
isn't actually as as beneficial to
society as as
i would i would hope it would be and
that's that's not coming from bernie
sanders that's
that's coming from a guy with an mba
yeah 100 man the
last bastion that all capitalists i'm
one of them
have to stand at like we will make our
stand here
is supply and demand it's the fact that
the market will reflect the demand for a
product and there's only so far that you
can get on
hype and clout and um just
a charming guy in a meeting eventually
you will run up against the market in
and it is a immovable object
and if you're if you're not an
unstoppable force the markets
the market's going to bum you um and
it would appear that that's what's
happened with wework
so before we get on to the downward
slope can you lay the landscape
of just how vast that operation was and
can we also talk about the amount of
wealth and investment that they'd
accrued including that particular
asian investor sure um
so you know by the by 2019 by the spring
of 2019 when i when i started
reporting on on the company i think and
this
the first location opened in 2010 um in
in soho in
new york city uh by 2019 they had more
than 400
uh 30 plus countries five different
continents
they were just opening in africa and in
johannesburg
hundreds of thousands of members
as they called them not not tenants um
and and the reason and and by all
accounts as adam newman himself put it
um
uh and and and probably accurately uh
this was the fastest
physical expansion by any company ever
and that's
that's probably true he he very coyly
said that he wasn't sure
uh about roman times and that there may
have been uh
high growth startups in in roman times
um
but uh it it grew incredibly fast and
the reason they were able to do that is
because mainly on the one hand and i
think it's worth
giving credit where it's due they
provided something that people wanted
wework offices were cool um they had
good coffee
you could meet cool people flexible if
you wanted to get out next month you
could do it you didn't have to sign
a five ten year lease there are all
kinds of reasons that
that's a problematic business model but
it was a thing that people wanted
the other thing as you allude to is that
adam newman was extremely good at
raising money um and
that started with him just kind of
raising money from friends and family
uh the first big round of investment was
from benchmark which is a big silicon
valley
firm they were the earliest major
investor in uber
uh big early investor in instagram
um and just kind of a classic silicon
valley
venture capital firm um it was a was a
big question of why they
exactly they were investing in this in
this um
real estate company that was that was
not a tech company like the ones they
they typically invested in but
but once that happened um you went
through a series of investors kind of
some
some blue chip names the jp morgan's the
goldman sachses
of the world um eventually
getting to this point in 2016 when
wework has has more or less tapped out
most of the available sort of private
money that you'd be able to get um
from from those banks in new york to the
silicon valley firms
they had recently scored an investment
in china um
but then what happened is that adam met
masio shusan
and mashyoshi or as he's known by pretty
much everyone
masa is a japanese businessman he
he runs a tech conglomerate called
softbank
um and softbank has a has a long history
he founded the company in
in the 1980s he's he's ridden various
waves in the tech boom from you know
selling cds and cd-roms and floppy disks
back when that's what you did up through
doing a lot of work and getting
broadband in japan
and and mobile technology and
and what he did in 2016 is he created
this thing called the vision fund
and the vision fund was a 100 billion
dollar
venture capital vehicle um with various
investors the
most significant one by far was the
government of saudi arabia which
invested 45 billion dollars
of 100 billion dollars which
you know invites all kinds of questions
that that we can talk about but but the
upshot of it was that
you know saudi arabia was trying to
diversify its economy away from oil
and masa was someone who was known for
taking big bets
he that that's what he's done throughout
his his career is being willing to take
huge risks and frankly in some cases
fall on his face
and get back up and and do it again and
so he had promised
to saudi arabia to some other entities
um apple
foxconn were also investors um in the
fund
that he was going to go out and find
basically the companies of the future he
sort of talked about it as kind of
building
a new version of warren buffett's
berkshire hathaway where you would have
this kind of conglomerate of of
companies and instead of it being
airlines and newspapers and and whatever
else and trains
it was going to be tech companies and
and focused particularly on artificial
intelligence and masa had become very
sort of obsessed with
the singularity and and the idea that
you would be you know harder to
differentiate between
humans and robots and all the
consequences um
that that would happen there
and he stumbled onto wework and and um
there again
as with benchmark there are all kinds of
questions about why exactly softbank
um decided wework was a good investment
um as a firm that typically invests in
in tech companies
um but ultimately uh softbank invested
initially more than four billion dollars
which was more money than than wework
had raised up to that point
um back in 2017.
and they followed that with another two
billion dollars a year later
and that uh was the money that really
gave jet fuel to to wework's growth
and at least in hindsight may have been
sort of a
sort of poison chalice is is one way to
look at it that
obviously turning down something like
that is is hard to do
um but it may have kind of
pushed the company sort of over a cliff
taking it on hastens the arrival of the
inevitable
exactly exactly and it's yeah it's it's
something you think you want
um but you know and again this this
i come up with other companies i wrote
about um it's hard to spend four billion
dollars it's hard to do that
responsibly um in in any way that kind
of makes sense and and there's certain
ways in which
you know you can you can point out sort
of individual
managerial missteps but in some ways
it's it's almost just an impossible task
to do that in a way that that would it
would really make sense
wasn't it right that the japanese
investor whose name i'm not going to try
because i'm going to butcher it wasn't
it right that he decided to invest
after 15 minutes of a meeting with adam
is that true
you know it's it's it's more or less
true um 28 minutes is what they say
uh you know yeah and and he is sort of
known
from known for doing that you know i
talked to someone else who
who had a company that south bank
invested in and and and
that's basically what happened is he had
a 10-minute meeting with masa
masa decided he wanted to invest would
have what of course is sort of left out
of all these stories
is after that
months and months of due diligence is is
done but what masa himself has
has said over and over is that often his
feeling
uh in that first moment when he meets an
entrepreneur um
you know his his most successful
investment was he was
one of the earliest investors in alibaba
the sort of chinese
um amazon and he made that investment
um he's often said just basically
because he believed in jack ma the the
entrepreneur he's sort of
he has sort of described it in these
kind of like primal terms
of of just a feeling that he had as as
much as anything else so
um you know he's also said with the
vision fund uh
he's he's described his meeting with
muhammad bin salman the
at the time soon to be crowned prince of
saudi arabia
as it took him 45 minutes to raise 45
billion dollars
and so he clearly prides himself and in
some ways lives on this reputation
of i make gut calls and then and then i
move on to the next one
that's mental like it's just
it sounds great and it's wonderful in a
book
and he's cool when tweeted online and
hearts to a man
who has the vision vision fund a man who
has the ability to see that which other
people cannot
are you like mate this
isn't me trying to get the next
motivational speaker
to work in the hr department of your
company
this is me doing very very complicated
multi-faceted financial products that
require the the most
clinical dissection to work out what the
hell is going on
and you're doing it based on whether or
not this person like i could send
i could send one of the 18 year olds
that works for me in club promo
one of the event managers i've got who
are just brimming with testosterone and
charisma
send them in as the pretend someone of
something
and this so anyway i that i think
lays the land quite nicely we've got the
fact that
this was huge growth that
he had a lot of money behind him can you
give the elevator pitch for how
wework made its money like what the
actual
core of their money-making operation was
sure um it was essentially a rent
arbitrage so the idea is
they um would go to a landlord uh lease
a building
um or or a floor of a building
um and you know they would pay a certain
amount of money to that
landlord let's say it's a hundred bucks
um and then
they rather they would then slice that
office into
that office up into um a hundred
little offices um rent it out to 100
people
and each rented out to them for about 50
so then
you know they're making um 150 bucks
that's essentially the business that's
it
it's it's as simple as that and it's
it's frankly as old as time
um and and that was what was so
confusing
to people is that this is a business
that existed before
um wework had made the offices cooler
um they had done an amazing job of
branding
which is not insignificant but the idea
of of taking big spaces and and cutting
them up into smaller offices is
something that
it's happened all the time regis which
is a company based out of europe um
is is sort of the most most prominent um
most prominent example
and so that that was kind of what was
most confusing about
people or two people who were skeptics
of it is
is that's that's a tough business and
it's it's a risky business because
what happens and and we've seen this now
is when you hit
what happens when you hit a downturn and
and i think you know
if if suddenly all 100 of your tenants
or even 50 of your tenants leave
then you're underwater um and and if
that happens at the scale that wework
had grown
um that's that's going to be a problem
um
and i think that's you know an
underrated
sort of part or maybe under considered
part of the success of
a lot of these unicorns over the past
decade is that the economy did nothing
but grow
basically from the 2008 recession up
until
the the pandemic that we're all
experiencing by and large it was an
upward trajectory and so
none of these companies had to deal with
kind of what had had fallen
or deal with doing business in a
difficult climate so
you know wework tried to to make money
other ways i mean the apartment business
didn't quite work the elementary school
wasn't
wasn't making money you know they tried
to get people to pay for extra printing
but those are those are marginal
things this is not like a software
business where you're
going to be selling more and more
services the more and more you get
people in on your business
essentially it just came down to renting
out space for a certain amount and
hoping you could lease it out to other
people for
for more money me and you could do that
i mean you could we could get whatever
that nice apartment that you're in now
with that
painting of a very majestic castle is
this is this is a wework in uh austria
like me and you could do that and this
really is
like the elephant in the room the crooks
of the story
that wework was positioning itself as a
tech company
it was billing itself as a tech company
it was telling people it was a tech
company
but it was the oldest of old-time
real estate and it was just skimming off
the top the difference between
long lease versus short lease and
once you get below your minimum
occupancy to
hit breakeven point which is inherently
risky when you allow
this hyper flexible one month minimum no
month minimum rolling contract
[ __ ] you are left holding
400 plus properties across six
continents
all of which can't be occupied during a
pandemic which
no one could foresee but you certainly
could foresee if there is
ever a downturn if there's ever a reason
for people not to go to work or just
generally a recession
our costs are going to go up and our
income is going to completely disappear
off the face of the earth
yeah yeah i mean to go back to your
point like yeah
you and i could run one of these spaces
there are people like you and me who do
them
they don't run 400 of them you know and
and
like you know i i you know speaking for
myself
and and others you know what adam newman
had partly was
was the same and why he and and masa
from softbank were
were sort of came so neatly together is
is a very high risk tolerance
and and a willingness to sort of say
this doesn't
totally make sense but there's an
argument for it there's an argument
that we could kind of make that that
this might work
and so you know that there's there's a
very thin line between
between you know the kinds of risks that
pay off and
and the ones that ends up with you
collapsing and i think
some of this just comes down to
temperament and we start the book with a
quote from
adam newman's high school driving
instructor
who um you know recognized in kind of
just the way that he operated as a
teenager
the thing that he said in in a class in
in israel where adam grew up was
was adam's either going to be a
millionaire or he's going to jail
like those are the two options there's
no like nice steady adam newman work his
way
up the ranks at some job he was he was a
go big kind of person
and and the question was going to be
um you know whether he he he ended up
being successful with that risk or or
falling on his face or both
or both i mean and that's sort of the
central irony here and i think is
a real central irony of of a lot of
this era i mean you can look around it
at other examples i mean i mean billy
mcfarlane's in prison so
you know he i i think he he
he clearly has has fallen on his face
but but for adam
um he's rich he's he's gonna be wealthy
um for the rest of his life um in theory
he has a billion dollar package that
is currently tied up in in some legal
maneuvering but
um you know
the risk paid off for him personally and
and he's gonna have some reputational
sort of work to do but but the risk paid
off take us through the downfall
what happened and also it happened to be
when you began reporting on them have
you considered that
uh i i i think that i played a very very
very very small
pivotal but i showed up um
a few days before adam went on his 40th
birthday party
um uh around the world trip uh
that ended up in the maldives um he's a
big surfer as i've mentioned
and um while they were there this was in
april of 2019
um they uh decided to go public and
and this had been a thing they had been
kind of tossing around but but didn't
want to do and adam didn't want to do
because
if you're that you sort of have that
temperament it's a lot easier
to just be able to connect with masa and
say we're going to go take this big risk
once you
become a public company you have
shareholders to to report to and
and you know you're going to have to
explain why you're why you're opening an
elementary school
um and so from there it was basically
an extremely chaotic summer um
a lot of the companies you're seeing
going public now
the airbnb's of the world they've been
preparing for this for a long
time um we work in in certain ways had
been there had been an
early pre-masa moment where they
considered going public and
and very faithfully uh decided not to
um but it was it was a sprint and it was
a sprint from
april to the end of the summer when the
company
released what's called an s1 um
and and the s1 is a document uh
is again this document that you you send
to the sec
and it has all these um
all this information on on how your
business works basically that that is
meant to give to investors
and so from the beginning it was
clear you know these documents are very
boring documents they are pages and
pages of charts
and graphs and uh disclosures
in very small font um in the beginning
the very first page i've i've just
looked it up so i could read it verbatim
the very first page of wework's version
of this said
we dedicate this to the energy of we
greater than any of us but inside each
of us
again it's sort of uh you can ask lots
of questions about what that uh that
actually means
um but uh the point is
if you're a financial investor and
that's the first thing you see you're
sort of like huh
um and so you know then from there it
was it was
a sort of shockingly quick um
turn of public opinion against the
company and again some of that was
people finding out about adam
and his quirks for the very first time
and sort of being like what the heck
is is going on here what sort of
what's that what sort of quirks um
the fact that he um
he and his wife uh rebecca who is also
um sort of came into the company
later on as as sort of a an executive
and was sort of the driving force
um behind the company um the fact that
they had so much control
was was one big thing and so much
control that that when they wanted to
start an elementary school
they didn't really tell many people
about it and it just
kind of happened um and and so some of
it was just sort of the control that
they had over the company but if you
want to talk about
some of the weirder stuff um
and and some of it's not weird in fact
you know it's uh for one thing
adam surfed a lot uh that's okay lots of
people
like to surf a lot um but wework was
also
invested in a wave pool company a
company that made one of these kind of
inland surfing pools that are now
becoming vaguely popular but didn't seem
to have anything
to do with uh wework's business
um it came out sort of you know
sort of an open secret that that adam
smoked a lot of marijuana
um and that again uh in and of itself
um not the strangest thing in the world
but
when you have uh you know the ceo of a
of a company sort of
um doing this as as kind of regularly
and openly as as he seemed to be
um it it led people to uh ask a lot of
questions
um and then i think the the the main
quirk i guess
to circle back to the that sort of uh
epigraph that i
mentioned was just the way that he
talked and and the way that that we
were talked about what they were doing
and the fact that they
talked they didn't they they just
wouldn't state the obvious which is
we're a real estate company they
insisted on saying
you know we are elevating the world's
consciousness
uh that this is all about the energy of
we and
and all of this stuff that that i think
on the one hand
i'm in favor of elevating the world's
consciousness whatever that
may mean yeah the energy of we
sounds like a good thing but i think at
a certain point it became
clear to people that it it purposefully
or not it was distracting it was
distracting from the main the actual
reality of what was going on which was
we were provides nice office space but
you know elevating the world's
consciousness is not something that
it does do you know the british term
all talk and no trousers uh
no but you can imagine what it means
where it's going
that's adam newman like um
this is again the corollary for adam is
is uh
i'll talk no shoes because he would walk
around
without wearing shoes how did i guess um
i think that's another part of it it's
not only the comeuppance of
an undeserved company overall
but it's someone in the adam position
who
from the outside looking in has a number
of things
that the
especially like the normal working class
guy
or girl would find pretty difficult to
deal with
spending a lot of time surfing spending
a lot of time smoking weed
decides to employ his wife probably on
some ridiculous retainer package
for someone who i'm sure that she has
many talents but i bet that she's
less qualified than many other people
who could have got that job
uh and then this rapping
in 2020 awakened like
austin's psychedelic language is
is the icing on a very twatty cake
yeah and i think it's you know getting
calling people on hypocrisy
is is almost tiresome because there's so
much of it but
but like the you know then it never gets
old man never gets older i guess so
the the the newmans you know talked
constantly about making the world a
better place they talked
constantly about climate change and
sustainability um
they flew all over the world on a
private jet they had
seven homes at least um new homes
kept emerging as i as i would continue
doing this this reporting um they lived
a very lavish lifestyle and
and again it's it's sort of you know i i
don't want to totally
criticize that i like having nice things
but
you can't you can't really have it both
ways you can't say
i'm all i care about is literally adam
said like i want to change the world
that's all i care about well
no clearly there there are other things
and
very material things um that meanwhile
a lot of a lot of your employees frankly
are not getting to benefit
from 100 there's a couple of quotes uh
one in particular that i really liked
hyperbole autocratic leadership and a
disconnect from reality
were suddenly assets on the path to
power and that
really in a sentence i think highlights
the um growth at any costs or growth
that by any means
uh obsession that we've got
coming out of this sort of angel
investment
world from silicon valley and i tweeted
something today which said that
the internet has permitted sociopaths
and charlatans to con
people at scale and it really does feel
like there's a
a particular um matrix
framework that you would be able to
create
for these people the billy mcfarlands of
this world the adam newmans of this
world
the uh it was the it was theranos lady
elizabeth holmes the elizabeth holmes is
of this world
like there is common threads between
them all that weave them together into a
particular type of person
and the scary thing is that all they
needed was the right company
like the key issue behind elizabeth
holmes from theranos
from adam newman from wework and billy
mcfarland from five festivals their
product was [ __ ]
like fundamentally their businesses did
not work
like specifically with theranos like you
said it was going to do a thing and it
didn't at least adam newman actually had
offices
they just weren't financially
sustainable and they were the um
minimum occupancy was too high it was
too risky uh billy mcfarlane
did not deliver a festival elizabeth
holmes did not
test your blood um but between them all
there's some common threads so i want to
get into the theranos story just a
little bit because it's just it's
just fun um before we do that what are
the lessons
that you think the world should take
away from the wework story
i've been thinking about this a lot
especially you know i i started
writing this book before um the pandemic
began
um and we are in an
era where for better or worse
a new world is going to be built
and and adam maybe down to new world
uh new things are going to be built um
frankly more easily than than they once
were because
you know as as with the adam newman
wework story um
he built it out of the recession it
wouldn't have worked if he
if he had started at another point he
started it at this sort of trough when
real estate prices were low and
and you could do something kind of
different and so
we're at the beginning of some kind of
new cycle and and i think
as as i look back um
on on this story and and this era
trying to figure out the fine line
between
um i guess to sort of take what you said
being being charming and being a
charlatan
is is a crucial sort of radar for
for all of us to develop and and i don't
you know it's it's tricky to know which
person is going to fall on
on which kind of line but i but i think
you know we can look at this in our in
our politics
um in business in everywhere we've we've
become
more and more i think keen to follow
kind of charismatic leaders
um and there's no easy solution
to to solving that but i think
being wary i guess being wary of
charisma
um and and thinking more about about the
numbers and
and the data behind anything is is
something that
we'd all would do well to to follow
i agree man it is the cult of
personality
is just so so strong and
um i wonder how much social media has
played into this you know like
previously
people who were famous or talented or
competent or whatever um they felt like
so untouchable you know like there were
these
angelic symbolic difficult to reach
barely human individuals that you would
hear about or that people would go to a
street parade to catch a glimpse of
and now like i know what kim
kardashian's dog's called because she
uploads like 45 i mean i'd obviously
don't follow kim kardashian on instagram
but i imagine if i did i would know what
her dog was called and it's okay if you
do i think
i promise you i promise you i i don't
someone's going to go and check but i
i know i don't um yeah
we we have this desire for transparency
and this cult of personality i think is
being fed by
the ability to see behind the curtain
you know
like president of the united states man
like he's
tweeting all the time and i think it's
thoroughly entertaining but i think it's
incredibly unpresidential
um and the fact that
you have this ambassador
for the personality
uh frontier being the most powerful man
on the planet
is that well if he can do it yeah and i
you know um adam newman was very good
friends with jared kushner
um they were you know both new york real
estate people
um adam newman and donald trump were new
york real estate people and it's
it's not new that that you know this
kind of bombast
can can get you far um it does
feel as if it can get you farther than
it once did um
that it's maybe a litter a little easier
to sort of pull the wool over people's
eyes and
yeah i think i think social media and
and the way it enables
anyone to kind of um build
a global brand off of very little um
sometimes you can back that up uh
sometimes you can get by without
having to back it up for a while but
eventually at least that's what
we'd like we'd like to believe um
eventually there there will be some
consequences for it and i think there
was in the wework case
um we'll see in the president's case and
and
in others but um yeah i think that's
certainly the case
they get found out right um
yeah i mean the thing with social media
is that you can scale
clout in a way that you never could
before
previously to become famous you had to
do something
not just be someone and the fact that
you can be famous
for just being someone not like louis
xiv
just be someone not like dynasty wealth
uh bourgeois living in some baroque
mansion somewhere not that kind
of be someone i mean like just reality
tv
spend six weeks on the right tv program
and come off and the entire country
knows your name
um like that is fame
for fame's sake as opposed to fame for
talent
or capability or hard work or whatever's
sake
um but as with many things that hollow
like that when you
come up against slightly tougher times
or when you decide to actually stress
test that fame you find that it's
incredibly hollow
and you're like oh actually there's
nothing in here like hit it with a
hammer and it
cracks and splits everywhere and you're
like oh that was all it was i thought
that
this was the elon musk i am allowed to
have this much bravado
because of how much uh gusto i've got
behind me how
virtuous and sort of uh reliable this is
so i want to finish off on the elizabeth
holmes theranos story if anyone doesn't
know or is interested if this um
slow motion car crash sounds interesting
first off go and buy a billion dollar
loser linkedin show notes below
uh the the fantastic book that we've
just been talking about
um but also on amazon prime just search
theranos
t-h-e-r-a-n-o-s and there's a really
really good documentary
about it what parallels can we draw from
adam newman to elizabeth holmes
i you know i'll start by saying the one
difference which you hinted at earlier
is that you know wework worked the the
business was there it was a real thing
there were offices
uh people liked them they paid money for
them um
all of those things was was a very real
difference
but it was interesting that you know i
started reporting on this just as i
think that
that documentary was coming out and i
was talking to wework employees and
and they were suddenly feeling kind of
nervous
having watched this this theranos
documentary and i think some of the
similarities are
obviously in in the two leaders um
elizabeth holmes
was you know became famous uh as as you
said um
[Music]
with without having the real or any
anything real to sort of
sort of back that up um adam had become
this
this a similar kind of figure um
you know there there were there were
things like the stratification of
information
i mean you you look at these two
different two companies and
you know they both of them kind of
became so big so fast you were kind of
in your own corner and and you assumed
that there are adults in the room you
assume
that there are kind of checks and
balances going on which is like what we
all hope i mean that's the only way to
like
go through your day um with some kind of
healthy skepticism but some kind of
belief that
that people are running the numbers and
and i think
you know in both cases that uh that
failed
um failed people and then and then the
checks and balances on that point you
know
a lot was made about with theranos there
were no doctors
on its on its board it was all kind of
big names who had been kind of wooed
by by elizabeth holmes and and charmed
by her and
and that was the case with adam it was
kind of these finance people there was
not a real estate person on on wework's
board of directors
um which which was in some ways an
intentional move wework didn't want to
be seen that way
and um and it's a lot easier to sort of
pretend
pretend that you're something else the
partitioning of information is really
interesting and
it's telling that that's how every
secret service across the world works as
well
yeah yeah it's you know it it's
it's a convenient way to run an
organization
so long as someone is is sort of
making sure they're all working together
but when
when the danger is of course when like
one one part of it the organization
isn't holding its weight it could all
kind of crumble so man i
uh i really enjoy this
story i don't know what it is about it
and i wonder if the people listening get
the same sort of satisfied i know that
they do
everyone listening gets this same come
up and satisfaction they're calling out
of hypocrisy
uh yeah and a billion dollar loser
linked in the show notes below if you
enjoyed this story then go and check it
out
any other things that people should
check out online any other places you
want to send them reeves
um you know you can go to
billiondollarloserbook.com and that's
that has kind of all the information
about about where you can you can buy
the book and
and um you know i'm on i'm on twitter
and
not really on instagram but uh you can
you can find all my
my other thoughts on this and other
things uh on twitter so
peace i don't follow kim kardashian
either
and on that note so you and i are the
only two people in the world
who don't follow kim kardashian right
sorry kim
but for now ladies and gentlemen i'll
catch you next time